*Pa Pa Pa*
This is the moment you've all been waiting for,
on this channel.
That's right.
I'm gonna draw, from my own MIND.
*Power effects* I know.
Better than the Br0Fist!
THIS IS WHAT EVERYONES BEEN WAITING FORRRR!
So, This started out from a live stream, I tried to draw Sonic.
*cute laugh*
I tried to draw Sonic from my memory...
It wasn't the best, okay, but at least I tried.
So I wanna try to do that again and draw these cartoon characters.
That exist in my mind but when you put them down on paper.
it is surprisingly hard, OKAY?
It's a lot harder than it looks! Don't judge me!
Here we fricking go!
Aaa, Pikachu, a classic.
Let's go!
I actually used to draw Pikachu a lot when I was a kid,
so I have a rough idea how this bad boy looks like.
Look at this, I know you're amazed already
KA CHOW!
I know ALL the details.
Now you gotta get those cute little furry eyes.
Then you gotta get that sparkle in there.
That actually..oh god.
That actually just looks like he's missing a soul.
Get that cute little nose! KA-
How is the mouth of Pikachu, by the way?
Is it like.. yess, ye- *laugh*
It's kinda cute, I like it!
This should be the new Pikachu.
How T H I C C is Pikachu?
This is starting to look like Big Chungus.
Alright, see has his little cute little arms, right?
He has three fingers.
Pikachu has three fingers. Everyone knows this.
That looks like an extra s.. pack of skin or something...
"What's a pack of skin," you might ask..
I don't know. I don't make the rules.
I just draw him, man..
I actually practiced drawing Pikachu as a child...
and this is what it led up to.
Okay..
Yes!
Let's not forget the tail,
and the belly.
Now let's color in this bad boy!
Deviant artists are shaking right now.
They know they'll stand no chance.
No, that's not right...
Uhh, what's the color of belly?
Maybe he doesn't have a belly...
Alright, let's look at the.. let's look at the comparison..
Ah shit I forgot the cheeks!
Oh my god! Noo, the cheeks!
*laughs*
Noo it's so bad!
I was so happy until I saw...
*laughs*
I was actually proud of it, until I saw...
Wait, wait let me just draw the cheeks...
LOOK AT THAT, NOW IT'S A PIKACHU!
Frick you, OKAY? I don't need your abuse.
Next 👏drawing 👏!
Minions, ok another yellow creature...
God damn this is gonna be hard...
Alright, here we go.
The shape of the minion.. is easy,
cause it's the shape of my pp..
Then of course, the classic cyclop eye.
Alright so far.. so good
Why is drawing the circle so goddamn hard?
Yeah, I'm happy with that.
Now that's about it!
PUHAHAHAH
How do the eyes look like...
Is it like that?
Is it like a sirens eye...
Oh god.. what is happening?
Why does he look like he's about to do something to me...
I don't like this
How does it.. ahh
How do the arms look like?
Ahhh.
I feel really uncomfortable...
I assume they have gloves cause all cartoons have gloves.
Alright, Pixar Animation Studios if you're listening and if you're hiring..
just let me know, cause this isn't my Minion apparently.
Alright, what does a Minion actually looks like?
Well that's not... ahh
oh..
It's not too bad, right?
*laughs*
I don't know how you can mess up a Minion, though, but...
So, apparently they have hair, I didn't notice.
Hah,  you learn something new everyday.
Incredible.
BaNanA.
Hilarious.
Thank you.
Next challenge!
SaNs?
Sans from memory?
Are you crazy?
Should I try to do the pixel art...?
*laughs*
Yees bitch, Sans!
This is how Sans was made.
Fcking hell, it's terrifying what have I done
ahahahhahahahhah
It's  so ahahahh
I'm trying Sans
I'll do your justice I'll do your justice Sans
I'm sorry
Did I get anything right?
The nose is not too far off at least
See, I was wondered if he was chessless and he is
I tried ok? I tried
*pewdiepie noises*
Handsome squidward
Now that's a challange
that I'm up for
absolutely let's go
oh, god
I know he has like a big chin right
*pewdiepie noises*
noo
no
*laughs*
I'm actually trying
oh god
*loser laughs*
Ohh god, you just never know how incompetent you are until you try
Does he has che- .. ahh
I'm not even gonna finish any further
cause I just know ahahaha
Oh my god
I need a break, Jesus Christ
Mario without a moustache
now Mario was another character I liked to draw as a child
So maybe this won't be too bad
Cause this is just embarassing
Mario
I've seen him a million times
But how in the frick does he look like
He has a big nose
Yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
It's all coming
Well I'm drawing like kids draw
When they try and replicate something
That's how my drawing looks like
I swear I'm not this bad
It looks like a three- year- old did this
Alright let's just, let's just get it over with
Let's just look at the result
Oh my god, I forgot to draw the moustache
It was supposed, I was supposed to draw Mario without a moustache
and I just forgot to draw it
and I thought it was it
*laughs*
I know technicaly, like
it was supposed to be without a moustache but I kinda wanna see how if it
salvages anything
Yes
YES
That's Super Mario right fricking there
Heck yeah
You're welcome guys
Sonic's live action design
release yesterday the new sonic trailer
Surely I can't make it look any worse than it was in that trailer
So let's just fricking do this
I think what freaked everyone out was the fact that he had human teeth
At least that's what I was bother by
This is something uneasy about having human teeth
Why does he look so creepy I'm trying
I'm scaring myself how did this happen
I'm trying to draw
why can't I draw Sonic I don't understand
If you're judging me right now, you should try drawing anything
from memory
It's really hard
Especially these very spesific designs
are you fcked up this badly
How is this possible
*laughs*
Oh god
God, forgive me
*pewds laughs*
What did I get right
nothing
Dude he has ears, I didn't remember ears
I got the mouth pretty well to be honest
Sega Team if you need help, just hit me up I got you
You know what you got some harsh critics but clearly people don't understand
how hard it is
to draw a perfect Sonic
I'll do one more, one more
cause I feel disgusting
ok, here we have Shrek
Drawing Shrek from memory
I feel like this should be,  if there's one thing that I should be able to draw from my own memory
It's ghaah, it's gotta be Shrek because
I have not looked on a man with any more detail than I have ever looked at Shrek
I know his ins and outs
impeccably
as you can see
I'm already doing amazing
It's got a very round face
now the question is, what is on that face
well, he's got a big smile, no
he's got a, he's got a big smile right
ok, ok alright
nose, I'm just gonna guess that it's a big nose
I don't really remember
this is like a really cute ver..
This is so cute, oh my god he's adorable
Has anyone drawn Shrek this cute? I don't think so buddy
He's got these weird patches on his head too right
Oh, no we're entering uncanny valley again
No, god damn it.
I messed up somewhere.
Oh god he's so chunky...
Oh,
oh no...
no
I'm just gonna stop.
Thank you guys for watching me draw out of my memory and thank you for your wonderful suggestions.
Ok, honestly tho, was I too far off on the Shrek?
Let's skip the torso bit...
I think that's pretty close. I think that's pretty good.
Thank you!
Ten out of ten Picasso confirmed!
Thanks for leaving a smash like and as always, smile more!
BYE
What? You never played Tuber Simulator?
You know it's fun right?
I'm not supposed to give my opinion but give it a try.
And then you can tell me if it's good or not.
Not convinced yet? Okay, I'll cut you a deal.
The game is available for free, and that's a great price.